I've got a great book recommendation for
you today the book called predictably
irrational by Dan Ariely I am almost
done with the book I just got like the
last chapter to go and dan ariely in the
book goes through a lot of sort of
conventional wisdom about rationality
and his argument as the title of the
book suggests is that people are
irrational but in predictable ways and
this can include weight loss programs
this can include pricing and buying
decisions procrastination lots of really
really interesting points of view now I
will tell you this it's a very quick
read it's not exactly last week's
recommendation addiction by design
addictive by design addiction by design
from from Princeton University Press
it's a much more dense and academic read
that takes a much longer time to get
through predictably irrational by Dan
Ariely is quite a quick read not really
academic simple language sometimes it
feels like a little bit less than what
it could be but a really good
illustrator of some of the cognitive
biases that we can be affected by and
i'd be super interested in interviewing
dan Ariely very interesting history born
in israel suffered really bad burns that
are visible when you see him is
noticeable moved to the US went into
academia has worked with really
interesting people and his is a burn
accident relates to his work in many
ways that I've seen him discuss so
interesting guy really good book
predictably irrational yeah it's
interesting recommendation i'll have to
check it out I mean it seems like people
are always willing to take instant
gratification over what's going to
benefit them in the long term that's one
aspect of so I mean yeah just on the
premise alone I'm hooked some other
interesting stuff like for example when
you look at pricing theory and the
impact of things being free on
behavioral economics and buying
psychology just a lot of really
interesting stuff that I think can be
applied to sort of everyday life
predictably irrational dan ariely that's
my recommendation for this week check it
out along with all my other other
recommendations at david pakman.com
slash recommendations and of course if
you use the
links on that page to buy any of these
books or stream films you are also
helping to support the david pakman show
we will take a break we have a fantastic
program for you today i'm on twitter at
d taqman and the show is on Twitter at
David Pakman show please follow one or
both of us